Have you ever thought about
how naive it is to just use
the free Wi-Fi at cafes
and similar public places?
You are trusting the store
owner to not do anything dodgy.
And you're trusting that every
other person currently using
the Wi-Fi hotspot
is a good person.
Not only can they
listen to your traffic--
you are broadcasting over
radio waves, after all--
but they could also tamper
with the data you receive.
This is a harmless change.
But what if you wanted
to check your bank
account on a public Wi-Fi?
Think about every other person
being able to read or change
your data.
We definitely don't want that.
HTTPS is a way to protect
you and your users
from malicious cafe
owners and visitors.
As a web developer,
HTTPS is even more
important since
all modern browsers
API's are only available if your
website is secured with HTTPS.
To exploit the full
potential of the web,
you need to start
using HTTPS, and not
just for the log-in page,
but every single page.
Knowing a web page
is using HTTPS
will give your
users peace of mind
in these kinds of public places.
How can you tell if a
website is using HTTPS,
and how can you tell if
a website is using HTTPS
correctly, and how can you
use HTTPS on your own website?
That's what this
lesson is about.